I have the great pleasure of introducing
a friend as well as one of the most
prominent figures in the community.
Uh,
Sujin Quan Soojin is the managing director
of the MBA admissions and the overall
program at Michigan's
Ross School of business.
She's also an adjunct lecturer in
business communications at Ross.
Previous in her life, she was also
a manager at delight consulting,
an analyst with the U S Senate Budget
Committee and a presidential management
fellow with the White House Appropriations
Committee and Department of Commerce.
She holds an Mba from Ross,
a masters in public policy from Harvard's
Kennedy School of government and a Ba
in economics and political
science from Yale.
She's clearly not very accomplished.
Um,
we're thrilled to have Sujin here
to share perspective on her career,
her path,
and then a little bit about what's
happening in the Mba world for all of you.
So Sujin welcome and thank you for coming.
Thank you.
Thank you
for having me. When I'm Dong and
an angel asked me to do this,
I was thrilled then and the context they
gave me was there are a lot of Googlers
out there who are interested in thinking
about the next step in their career and
we thought it might be useful
for you to share your own path.
And so I'm going to start from way back
from when I was a child and when all of
us start to think about what do
you want to do when you grow up?
How many of you have thought about
that question since childhood? Right?
So when I was really young,
before I went to grade school,
I thought I would it be a cashier because
I thought you got to take home all the
money that you collected
at the end of the day.
And then I got a little bit older,
I got a little bit wiser and I saw
my parents working really hard.
My parents are immigrants from Korea
and my dad was an engineer and my mom
worked at nights fixing phones.
Um,
so she could be home while
we were home from school.
And they were constantly working and
taking care of us around the clock.
And I thought, wow, that is hard. All
I want to do when I grow up is retire.
My parents said, no,
you've got to first work.
So then as I went through
grade school and middle school,
I was one of a handful of Asian kids and
a very white community right outside of
Ann Arbor actually.
And I grew up with a lot of physical
and personal challenges to who I was
because of how I looked
and right or wrong,
I happen to watch the movie, the
Godfather with my dad when I was young.
And I thought, when I grow up, I want
to be the godfather because you can say,
take a hit out on that person. They've
crushed me. And my parents said,
so you didn't know.
That's not the way to get ahead.
So then when I got to high school,
what I saw was still my parents working
really hard and trying to make ends meet
and our ends met.
But we had things that we needed,
not always the things that I wanted.
And I thought,
what I want back to my childhood is money.
I need to go work in business.
So, um, I,
I also grew up playing the piano
quite well a long time ago.
And I had a decision to make
when I got into college.
I gotten into Michigan for music and
gotten a scholarship to study music.
But I also got into Yale,
not for music,
but for a liberal arts education.
And I chose the wind wind solution,
which was to go to Yale
because my parents are Asian.
They have a desire to
have bragging rights.
And Gail gave them bragging rights
with all their friends, um, that,
that we grew up with. And for me,
it was a ticket out of Michigan and,
and ticket to seeing more of the world,
learning with other people
who are not from Michigan.
And that really appealed to me. So
I thought, finally, I'll be free.
I can do whatever I want to do.
Except that my parents said, well,
you got to do something that's going to
get you a job and the thing that's going
to get you a job as a degree that's
going to lead to either another degree or
business.
So you're either going to do
premed or engineering or pre law,
something like that. I didn't want to
do any of those things, but they said,
if you want us to pay for
college or at least part of it,
you're going to have to major in
something that gets you a job.
So my compromise was economics
and political science.
I thought that's going to set me up to
potentially apply to law school because
that will lead to a profession.
Something that my parents could say
Soojin is now a lawyer or a doctor or
engineer. So it was something very clear
and it was something that was familiar.
It's something that I learned
about on TV back then.
Before there was Google back before
there was internet and Linkedin.
The only way you could know what career
paths were available were by the people
around you,
your parents,
their family and friends
and things you saw on TV.
So to give you another example,
my husband is a dentist and he knew he
wanted to be a dentist from a young age
because he saw the show
Rudolph the red nose reindeer.
How could that have led to
wanting to be a dentist?
There is a character on there.
How many have you seen Rudolph
the red nose reindeer? Okay,
so there are a bunch of elves and
there's one else Hermie who says,
I want to be a dentist. And the head
office says, no, you're a toy maker is,
but I'm really interested
in moles and things.
And so when he saw that
my husband Jim said,
I want to do something that makes me
different to the other thing that made him
realize he wanted to be
a dentist was growing up.
He had gone to his dentist and he was
always singing and whistling and this guy
was always happy and he thought when I
grow up I want to career where I'm really
happy and fulfilled in my career.
So that's what I want to do.
Even though we ended up
in very different places.
What drove us to our decision was that
we were influenced by the things that we
knew the people around us,
what we were exposed to,
and back before the Internet
it was really limited.
So most people followed in the footsteps
of their parents or their parents'
friends.
So fast forward to college and my senior
year at Yale I had to decide what am I
going to do next?
The obvious thing was to go to law school,
so to make my parents happy and be a good
Asian kid, I did apply to law school,
but what I really wanted to do after
taking a constitutional law class was work
on policies that would impact a
lot of people for the greater good.
And I discovered in the career office at
Yale public policy school and so I sent
away for information for that,
not telling my parents that I was doing
that and I got in and when it came time
to make a decision, my parents said, what
the heck is this thing called an Mpp?
What are you going to do when you
grow up after getting that degree?
Does it lead to a job and how
much will you make? I don't know.
I'm just going to take it on faith
that it will work out and so it did.
I did get a job.
I became a presidential management fellow
and what that program does is it gives
you leadership training as well as
rotational opportunities throughout the
executive and legislative branches and
that's what I did for a number of years
and it was great fun to be in the
middle of what was making news.
It's still making new stuff that happens
in DC, makes the news. It felt exciting.
It felt current.
It felt sexy until I realized I am just
one little cog in this big machine that
isn't having an impact on things
that really change the world.
And so I felt pretty useless and I thought
I need to do something else because
my heart is isn't really in it.
It was in it for the right reasons,
but I wasn't feeling like
I could have that impact.
So the next step was private sector.
At least there I can feel like I'm
working on something where I can impact
change pretty quickly, where I can see
the results of my brain power, my effort,
my working with other people. So I
said consulting. That's a thing for me.
It'll allow me to use my brain power.
It allow me to work with different people,
work on different projects. It'll
be exciting. There'll be sexy.
We're all in search of
sexy to some extent. Um,
so I threw a bunch of letters out their
cover letters to all the top consulting
firms.
I got nothing.
I thought I have a Yale
degree and a Harvard degree.
Surely that's going to get me
a job. Guess what? It doesn't.
It didn't cause I didn't know
how to apply for a job like that.
I didn't really know what it was.
I didn't know how to talk about
what I would bring to the table.
I didn't know how to talk
about their organizations.
I hadn't done my homework and
I didn't really know myself.
So I went back to the drawing board.
The answer is always school when
you don't know what to do next.
School is always a good thing.
So I decided to get my Mba because
still had in my mind that I wanted to do
consulting.
I went to the Michigan Ross School of
business right here in Ann Arbor and spent
the next two years doing things that
would set me up to be able to get a
consulting job.
And I did.
I landed a job at Deloitte consulting
and did that for about five years and it
gave me some of the things
that I was looking for,
which was using my brain power to make
change in an organization that I could
see. But after a number of
years of doing that, again,
I felt my heart saying
I need something more.
So I had to think about what is
that more that I'm looking for?
And that more was personal,
meaning where I'm having an impact on
something that makes somebody else's life
better, where it's getting
someone more opportunities.
That's about all I knew about
what I wanted to do next.
And so I had to really think about what
are the jobs out there that could give
me that,
where I can use my skills and get the,
the kind of the feeling that I want in my,
in my gut,
in my soul about having impact.
So I just started talking
to a lot of people,
people who do different things in their
careers and learning, what do they do,
what is it all about?
And as it turns out,
one of my conversations was with the
woman who had recruited me to come work at
Deloitte. She was a manager at the time.
And as soon as I took the offer, she said,
guess what? Sujin I'm leaving. I'm so
glad you signed. You made me look good,
but I'm going to go do something
else. I was like, what the heck?
I joined because I wanted to
work with you. As it turned out,
she went to go be the admissions director
at the Ross School of business and
over the next five years
that I worked at Deloitte,
I kept in touch with her and having those
conversations with her helped lead me
to my current job at the
Ross School of business.
We talked about what do I like doing,
what is it about some of the rules
that I've had that really excited me,
brought me joy,
made me feel like I was having the kind
of impact that I wanted and it was a
number of things.
One was in my free time.
I am an alumni interviewer
for Yale undergrad and one
of the things I love about
that is understanding people,
what motivates them, their dreams,
and is there a good fit
between what they want to do,
what they've done and what
that school can offer.
So that was one thing.
Another thing I realized was it Deloitte.
I really enjoyed recruiting new Mbas
because it was an avenue to opportunities.
It was promoting an organization that I
really loved and then I also liked using
my analytical skills in consulting,
figuring out how do I make something work
better? How do I get more of something?
How do I make it as good a process and
experience for people who engage with my
organization,
whether it's Deloitte or Yale or Michigan,
how do I make those things happen? And
so when I describe these things to her,
it became obvious to her Antony that
recruiting at Michigan might be a good fit
and opportunity happened to present
itself. She had an open slot there.
That's how I got here 13 years ago and
I haven't looked back because the things
that keep me here are some of the same
things I was looking for in a job.
Feeling like I have an impact on people's
lives and that helped them have better
opportunities in their own lives.
Getting to use my analytical skills,
the things that I learned in
the MBA program and working
in an organization that
I feel is mission driven and helps other
people and is doing really exciting
things.
It's sexy to work on leadership and
innovation and entrepreneurship and all
those things, and I'm surrounded by
faculty, students and alumni who do that.
And so when people ask me, what's next, I
say, why should there be a, what's next?
If I'm learning and I'm growing and I
love what I do because ultimately isn't
that what we're looking for?
At least one of those three things.
But if you have all three of those things,
you kind of have that trifecta.
So as I think about advice to people
who are early in their career,
how can you find the thing
that will make your heart sing?
I have a few things.
One is to research and explore.
Really talk to a lot of people.
Every person that you meet is going
to be able to teach you something.
I met Davon maybe seven, eight
years ago, not professionally,
but through an alumni event.
We're planting flowers. We
planted flowers together.
He and his wife in downtown Ann Arbor.
We were all doing volunteer work
that day and we happen to develop a
relationship that over the last seven
years I've watched him have two kids.
He seen my kids grow up.
I'm here now largely because of him and
meeting angel. Are you still in here?
Angel?
I met her at divine's house and we had
a great conversation about some of the
things that she did in Undergrad that I
was really inspired about her initiative
and her drive for creating a Ted
talk series at her institution.
I was really excited to hear things that
people do and it makes me want to know
them and know other people.
The other thing,
the second thing is to reflect on what's
important to you and where you are in
your life.
What's right for you,
really depends on where you are in
your stage of life. Who's in your life?
Who Do you need to take care of?
Do you have a significant other?
Do you have children?
Do you have parents who need to be taken
care of or can you right now focus on
yourself that should influence
the choices that you make.
And the other thing is what do you
need to do in your life right now?
Do you have a lot of other obligations?
Do you have personal goals
that you want to fit in?
Or can you really focus on career?
Those things can help you figure
out what is the next career for me.
Because at different times in your life,
those things are going to change.
And the last thing I would encourage
you to do is to stop and reflect.
Reflect on what have I
done so far in my life?
What have I learned with the
people that I've talked to?
What seems really interesting?
How did they get there?
What can I learn from them
or about how to get there?
And if you don't do this already,
I would encourage you to keep a journal.
And I know it can be hard,
I find it hard myself,
but keep a journal of the things that
you learn about yourself of the things
that were hard.
How you've tackled some of those problems,
things you want to change about
how you might approach something,
goals that you have,
but taking quiet time to sit down and
reflect about those things that can help
you also narrowed down what
what it is you want to do.
You guys are really lucky that
you work in a great place,
that you live in a time when you can
find out information about anything,
about anyone, anywhere in the world
and you can connect with them.
You were only a few degrees of separation
away from someone who may want to meet.
In some ways that might be harder
because that makes it seem overwhelming.
All those opportunities
that you could have,
but if you do those three things that I
suggested research and talk to people,
think about where you are in your life
right now and sitting down and reflecting
on what's important to you,
what you've done and who you want to be
that can help narrow your focus a bit.
One of the most exciting things about
meeting new people for me is thinking
about new ways of doing
things and new ways.
New things to do and some
people may call that networking.
I really call it getting to know people.
It's a really valuable skill and I have
to put in a plug of course for getting
an MBA and here's why,
because I will contend that
more than any other degree,
that's going to open up a
broader range of opportunities.
It can be opportunities,
financially, opportunities, industry,
function-wise opportunities
to meet different people.
If you were a dentist or
a doctor or an attorney,
you're career is that it will be almost
invariably that for the rest of your
life.
But when you get an Mba,
there's so many things you can do that
may or may not be related to business.
What it teaches you are ways to
think about things, problem solve,
and to work with other people and that's
what you're going to have to do any
field.
And so I contend that an MBA
is the most valuable degree,
the most flexible degree you can have
out there. And if you're going to do one,
you should get it at Michigan.
I'll stop there and turn
it over to the phone.
Well, first of all, thank you. Uh,
it's incredibly insightful
to hear about your journey.
More insightful to hear about how you've
made decisions at every stage in your
life. I'll start with a handful of
questions and as I'm asking questions,
I'll ask all the folks in the room to
also start thinking about questions or
jotting them down.
Um,
but let's start with one of the things
that really struck me is how you made
decisions at every stage in your life
based on a little bit of something that
felt uneasy,
something in your gut,
something that meant that you needed to
think about this itch that was kind of
happening and a change that you needed.
So I'd love for you to kind of talk about
how you thought about those decisions
and then ultimately any sort of guidance.
A lot of the folks in this room are
either in their first job or their second
job out of school and will soon be
coming to those points of inflection.
So any guidance you can
provide there would be useful.
Okay.
So there were many things that made
making these decisions challenging for me
along the way.
Part of it is my own culture and heritage,
wanting to being Asian,
obviously wanting to please my
parents and make them proud.
That is something that even now as I'm
approaching 50 is it looms really large
in my head.
The decisions that I make.
And so what I wanted to do wasn't
always what they wanted me to do and
reconciling that was really hard.
The other was reconciling kind of my
background and what I want to do is this,
the career path of someone who went to
Yale and Harvard to be an admissions
director who grows up wanting to do that,
getting an MBA and then
being an admissions director
eventually who grows up
wanting to do that.
So it felt like a very nontraditional,
unconventional decision to make.
And I'll be honest,
I have a lot of pride. Like
I want people to say, wow,
she's done something really great with
her life. She is accomplishing a lot.
And given the path that I was on,
it wasn't always clear to me that the
choice that I've made in this role was an
obvious one.
It takes a lot of courage to say,
but you know what? I
love this. I'm learning,
I'm contributing,
I'm making an impact.
I can make change and I'm
meeting really great people.
It took a lot of courage to me.
For me to say those things outweigh all
the other image related things that I
was. So it's so mired in, um,
and probably at a younger age,
it's harder to do that because you feel
there are things that you need to do,
maybe things that you need to prove either
to your family or to your friends or
to yourself. But at the end of the day,
what I've come to conclude and I can,
because I'm further in my career now,
is unless it's really making you thrive,
unless you feel like my heart is
singing, doing this, I'm learning,
I'm growing,
I'm doing things that matter to me,
then you're just spinning wheels.
Then it's just a job and nobody
wants to have just a job.
You want to have something
that makes you get up and say,
I can't wait to do this again.
I love the people I work with.
I love the things that I get to do.
I can't wait to do more of this
and when you stopped doing that,
when you stop learning,
when you stop growing and when you
stop being able to feel like you're
contributing, that's the time to
rethink what's the next thing?
Thanks Jen.
One more question along the same lines,
as the folks in this room are
thinking about their next steps,
I think often in the conversations
I've had and I've heard happening,
there's this almost conflict of do I
pursue something I'm really passionate
about versus going to get an Mba
and what role they both play?
How would you guide the folks in this
room to think about that conflict?
Okay.
I guess it comes down to a timing thing,
right?
If they think an MBA is in your future,
when is the right time to do it?
There really isn't a wrong time because
now there are so many different items in
your career that you can get it.
The Standard Path is with the
full time MBA coming out of uh,
out of Undergrad working for a number of
years and then going back to get your,
your MBA before you're 30.
There are also programs like at Ross
where you can do it part time while you're
working full time and then
there are programs like it Ross,
where you can get it when you've been
working for 10 or more years as an
executive Mba and it's at a
different level that you'll get it.
So there's never a wrong time. If you
have a great professional opportunity,
don't give it up.
If you feel like you're continuing to
do something where you're learning and
you're growing and if you took yourself
off that path to go get an Mba at that
point,
then wait a year.
But if you feel like there are skills
that I can gain now that only the Mba
could provide and my current job can't,
that might be the right
time to get it as well.
Thanks. It's a good transition to
thinking about like Mbas in general.
How would you describe Ross and what
you think makes [inaudible] unique?
One of the things that attracted me to
Ross almost 20 years ago and still holds
true today is that it's really focused
on allowing you to do things hands on,
not just sitting in class and learning
about theories and applying frameworks to
simulations,
but really getting out and doing
things that you might want to do,
whether it's consulting or managing
a fund or starting up a business.
All of those things you can do at Ross
while you're a student with faculty and
alumni advisers with
resources that are not yours.
It's you're putting at risk with the
help of classmates who have done some of
the things that you may want to do,
and so it's an incredible place where if
you want to actually do things and not
just learn the theory behind it,
you'll get that too raw.
There is no better place
to do that than at Ross.
Thanks.
When you think about the role of an MBA
in context of a person's career path or
life path, how has that changed
over the last 10 or 20 years?
I'd say it's changed quite a bit.
If you look at the industries
that students go into,
the recruiters that come to campus,
the choices that students make students
make about their careers post Mba,
it's just exploded 25 years ago.
People used to take pretty
standard pass banking, marketing,
consulting. Those were really the
three buckets that people went into.
Now people are doing all kinds of things,
are starting up their own businesses.
There are so many different kinds
of tech jobs, as you guys know. Um,
there are still students who go into
consulting and finance and marketing,
but those are not as
big as they used to be.
And it's no longer a career for life as
so many people who've got Mbas back in
the day.
Used to be.
It's you do one thing for a few years and
then you may pivot your career in any,
any number of ways.
And the beauty of the MBA now is it's
giving you the skills and the access to
pivot your career multiple times,
which students now are going to be doing
much more than even students from my
generation.
So I think that's one observation I have.
I've been in the workforce for 20
years and when I started candidly,
I would think getting a job
meant a job for life, right?
And now people are changing careers
quite frequently and probably five to 10
times over the course of their,
their entire careers.
What advice do you have in context of
careers and when people are thinking about
making those switches?
Okay.
The advice I'd give is to learn from
every role that you have learned,
not just the skills that are,
uh,
required for the position that you're in,
but also learn about yourself.
What motivates you, what about
that particular role at that time?
Really interested you so that you can
get closer to what it is that's going to
make, be your nirvana. And
it may change over time too.
Um,
I never knew that I would
love speaking as much as I do,
frankly.
Um,
it used to scare the heck out of me and
you could never get me to be the person
to stand in front of a class or
a large group to, to volunteer,
to speak and now through this role because
I had to because I've it quite a bit
and because I enjoy um,
sharing what I know,
I've learned that I love something that
I never would have imagined that I love.
So it's exposing yourself to different
things and getting good at everything
even if you don't love it because you
may find eventually you do love it and
that's the thing that makes you say,
this is so fun.
I can't wait to do it again.
Is there,
in your role,
you obviously shaped both admissions and
what the class looks like and you also
shape what the program looks like.
I'd love to hear from your perspective,
what are some of the biggest mistakes
applicant's make and then also in context
of students who are actually
pursuing an already in the program,
what are those mistakes? What are the
things people should be looking out for?
I think the biggest mistakes both as an
applicant and as a student are quite the
same.
It's inauthenticity.
It's trying to be someone that you're
not trying to make yourself at the
applicant stage look like
the quintessential Mba
applicant rather than really
just talking about yourself as you are
and what you want to do these days,
unlike 20 or more years ago,
there is no cookie cutter.
There is no traditional Mba candidate.
They are so different.
We have people coming from the Peace
Corps and from teach for America and from
the military, um, from
nonprofits, from medicine.
This wasn't standard when
20, 30 years ago. We,
um, my classmates and before
me were going to school.
I was a nontraditional student going
to business school at that time.
Most of my classmates had come
from some kind of business role.
I came from Capitol Hill.
I felt like a fish out of water.
But that's not uncommon anymore.
Students are coming with
really different backgrounds.
Yet a lot of Africans think they have
to look like the perfect business school
applicant. Same thing for when
students are in the program.
They get sucked into the,
Oh,
I should do consultant because everybody
else is doing consulting where I should
do finance because everybody
else is doing finance does this.
School is an opportunity to learn what's
out there and to learn what really
motivates you and then really
jumping into learning those things.
So you shouldn't have to feel like
you need to be this quintessential Mba
student either or post Mba.
You don't need to do the career paths
at all of your classmates are doing the,
the beauty of the degree is it's giving
you options to do different things.
And so I would encourage you guys to
have the courage to do really different
things.
Thank you. One more question
about the program in the class.
How are you thinking about
creating a diverse environment,
both from a perspective of the content
but also the program makeup in the
students and creating an
environment that's inclusive.
Okay.
I can't tell you how
important diversity is
to us. To me personally, um,
this year I'm really proud that our women
numbers are at a record high at 43% in
the MBA class.
I would love that to be 50,
50 more in line with what you
see at the Undergrad level.
Um, we truly believe that
without a diverse a class,
you're not going to learn as much without
people from different backgrounds with
different experiences.
We're going to make you think
about things in a different way.
You're just going to be thinking
the same way that you were before.
And the whole point of school is to
learn different ways of thinking about
things, about how your mind works and
how you approach situations and problems.
And if everyone comes from the same
industry or the same life circumstances,
you're not going to grow.
Our job is to give you an environment
where you were going to grow the most and
that is in large part through
the classmates that you have.
So we are so focused on making sure that
the student body, it looks very diverse,
not just in terms of gender,
but color, nationality,
backgrounds, geographies, career goals,
all those things matter because we
want you to learn from people who are
different from you. That's
great. Last question.
This is one to be a little
more playful and fun.
You're applying for an MBA program? Yes.
I'm, I told you I am a holding to it.
You're applying to an MBA program.
You can't apply to Ross.
What other program do you apply to?
Okay, I will give a nod to you
just because he's the cohost here.
Devonne went to Yale School of
management. Um, and that's my undergrad.
So it does have a special
place in my heart and that's
how I got to meet him. Um,
but I'm not endorsing it.
I'll tell you where we have the most
overlaps in applications because we have
visibility into that
from g mat test takers.
And then as we overlap largely
with Kellogg, with Duke,
with Wharton, Berkeley, Yale Talk,
all of those are great schools.
The thing is,
any of those schools
are going to be great.
It's about you making the most of the
opportunities that you have wherever you
are. But of course I'm pretty
partial to, Michigan has, uh,
the student body and the ex the,
um,
opportunity to do action based learning.
It's really different from all
the other schools. In my opinion.
But I encourage you to
check it out yourself.
If you're thinking about business school,
talk to students,
talk to alarms in every school
that you're considering.
Go visit because you're going to get
a feel for the school and for the vibe
there.
Cause that's gonna make the difference
between whether you get an Mba or he had
this great springboard for ideas and,
and opportunities. So it's about
finding the right place for you.
And you'll hear every
admissions director say that,
thank you for the authentic
answer. And it, it's very true.
I think your perspective on,
you know,
when you make that decision to go pursue
a degree, it's not just about the NBA,
it's about changing the way you think
and it can have a profound impact.
So thank you.